you know I think what the brain does
what the brain does is obviously it's a
survival Gadget right our brain evolved
because our ancestors in the African
Savannah and elsewhere in planet Earth
they were under pressure to to to find
the next meal to to get lodging that
would protect them from the harsh
environment and you look at us we're not
the strongest out there in the world
we're not the fastest right what do we
have we have cognitive abilities right
that are among the most sophisticated on
planet Earth I'm not going to say I
don't like you know this kind of human
singularism human exceptionalism per se
there are other intelligent creatures on
the planet but we're in the we're in the
upper echelon let's say relax sonar and
a few things so that's right that's
right exactly and and so what we did is
in order to survive we gained an Ever
more refined through evolution by
natural selection to fund Creative
Solutions to the challenges that we
faced rather than you know being able to
jump over that fast moving stream we
found a way of navigating through that
fast moving stream that most other life
forms wouldn't have found and so we've
been passed on this creative ability to
abstract and come up with Creative
Solutions we pass it on to the next
generation and they refined it and on
and on it went across the generations
and then when it comes to science
basically what is science science has
taken that capacity and pushing it well
beyond the needs of survival right we
don't need to understand electrons right
we don't need electrons or quantum
physics or black holes to get the next
meal or or to have you know shelter but
what our brains do is they overshoot we
go beyond the needs of mere survival and
so that creative Instinct that served us
well in the ancestral world now gives us
the capacity to understand
esoteric qualities of the world like
quantum physics and entanglement in
black holes in general relativity and so
forth so somewhere in that evolutionary
mix is the answer to your question but
if you ask me when I look at some of the
deep insights of physics and look you
know one of my specializations is in
relativity so Einstein of course is the
grand hero so I'll just use him as an
example but there are many when I look
at some of the ideas that Einstein
introduced into physics like curve space
time yeah I've tried to follow his
reasoning because I wanted to answer
your question where did this idea come
from yeah trace it back and you can post
facto make an explanation aha he was
thinking about this then this then this
and but I think we're just making up a
story I think at some level the human
brain rearranges ingredients it finds
new patterns it finds new combinations
and I Einstein had the ability to find a
radically new combination that nobody
had thought about before that ultimately
led to his greatest contribution the
general theory of relativity so
somewhere in that mix of a brain that
can creatively find Solutions
and just the wonderful architecture of
the mind that allows it to rearrange
pieces new ideas emerge
there's a thought that there's no UniQue
Ideas no new ideas is that do you
believe that to be true well it depends
of course how you defined Define the
word new
um I think the vast majority of ideas
are rearrangements of existing pieces
you know finding new patterns within
stuff that's already out there and to my
mind if that teaches you something if it
gives you Insight if it allows you to
leverage it to build something that you
couldn't have done before then I'm happy
to call it a new idea so I guess I'm
maybe a little less strict with my
definition of new but from from that
perspective I'd say the ingredients are
there but it's all about how you arrange
them and the patterns that you find then
what are we if we're pattern making
machines if we're meaning making
machines right what what exactly are we
I have a couple of answers to that and
they all interleave at some level and I
think in addressing an important
question like that you have to choose
the level of analysis that you're asking
the questions so if you ask me what are
we at the fundamental physical level I'd
say we are nothing but large collections
of particles atoms electrons protons
neutrons that have configured themselves
into a very specific coherent pattern
that allows us to navigate the world in
the manner that we do so answer number
one where bags of particles governed by
physical law that's mostly energy right
so empty space too it's mostly empty
space and the particles carry energy and
there's certainly is energy in the form
of radiation that we are immersed Within
and so yes there's a wonderful interplay
between the stuff that we're made of and
the ambient environment
I wouldn't want to stop my explanation
of who we are there because it's very
mechanistic and so I would start to
build up and if we had enough time I'd
go through a bit of chemistry a bit of
biology but let me go right to the level
of human mind because that's really I
think where we feel who we are and at
that level the language that you used I
would concur with we are meaning making
machines we are pattern recognition
devices we find it very useful to look
out into the world and organize things
as that helps us to survive and to gain
greater insight into the kinds of
behaviors that would be beneficial to us
and so we are bags of particles that
have the special ability to find
patterns to invent meaning and in that
way to experience the world at the level
that you and I are right now at the
conscious level that to me is still a
deep mystery
where does Consciousness come from but I
would say in between these two scales
bags of particles and meaning making
pattern recognition machines that sort
of spans the gamut of what we mean by a
human being do you agree with Elon Musk
that there's a very high probability
that we are a simulation it seems like
as pattern recognizers like and then we
we make these patterns essentially in
our world
that we're a pattern making a pattern
wouldn't a pattern make a pattern yes
and and there are many self-referential
versions of that statement you know we
are collections of atoms that can
contemplate atoms
we are massive
amounts of molecules that can make
meaning right I mean so there is this
wonderful juxtaposition between
our physical makeup the fact that
everything else in the world has its
physical makeup and we recognize that
because we are patterns of particles
with the capacity to find patterns in
other particles so I think it's a
beautiful a beautiful story about how
there's an objective world out there and
we can build a model of that objective
World in our subjective minds and that
allows us to navigate and and survive in
a way that would be difficult otherwise
as to the question though that you
started with with are we in a simulation
I would have to say from a gut feeling I
think I would like most people recoil at
that idea say the answer manifestly is
not true there are powerful arguments
and I don't know the one that Elon Musk
perhaps is making a reference to but
certainly you can imagine that
if in the future I don't believe that we
have this capacity at least here at the
moment but if we are able to build
artificial systems computers say that do
have sentience that do have an inner
world of conscious experience then yes I
think in the future it may be possible
to simulate worlds in which there are
beings inside the simulation yeah that
feel things right I don't I don't see an
obstacle to that in any fundamental way
I don't think I don't think that this
Gloppy gray biological thing inside of
our heads is essential to have the kinds
of experiences that we do I think if
there's a computational version of this
that does it correctly and that's a big
question how would you how would you do
that I don't see any obstacle for there
to be a feeling sensing being inside of
a computer I don't I don't see a
fundamental obstacle if that's the case
you do run into an interesting idea
which is in the very far future whatever
that means
it may be very easy to sit down in the
evening flip on a few switches
push a few buttons and create a whole
universe inside of a computer
and if everybody is doing this it's the
new fad you can imagine that there are a
gazillion of these simulated worlds
running in parallel on all these
computers and then you'd say well what's
the likelihood that this universe is not
one of the that this one is somehow
special it's a real Universe well I
think there's only one real Universe if
they're a gazillion simulated ones the
odds are we're in a simulation and
that's sort of the way that that
reasoning goes
um the big if can you create
Consciousness in a computer nobody
really knows the answer to that and the
other big if and this is emphasized by a
philosopher named Nick Bostrom at Oxford
just to give credit where credit is due
he said look maybe it's the case that
any sufficiently advanced civilization
that gains the capacity to understand
things well enough to make sentience
inside of a computer at the same time
they're also building sophisticated
weapons because apparently that that's
what smart beings do at least from this
one piece of data and they blow
themselves up before they get to the
point of creating these simulated worlds
maybe nobody survives long enough
because we're such an aggressive yeah
life form
um so that's the other way that you can
obviate this conclusion that we're in a
simulation or you can simply say hey I
don't believe that you'll ever have
Consciousness in a computer done end of
story I can see the pathway I mean if
there was something if Consciousness if
I was controlling if I was using a
controller and playing a video game then
I am
the Consciousness is still making that
player do something it is but it's still
channeled through you you know what we
what we think is a flesh and blood look
we've never met and right now you're
just a bunch of pixels on my screen but
I'm assuming that you're not some sort
of fancy video chat bot that there's a
real human being there uh and given that
you are still the initiator and the
origin of the Consciousness that's
driving your avatar in that video game
imagine though you don't need that that
the Avatar in the video game is so
sophisticated that it creates its own
Consciousness and maybe it can even
replicate within that world and have
children that are conscious
if you like this clip and you want to
hear the whole episode click at the
bottom of your screen